Десь на Бахмутській ділянці фронту, замаскувавшись у лісопосадці,
причаївся український артилерійський розрахунок.
Через півтора року війни їхня тактика змінилася.
Раніше ми працювали мобільно.
Тобто виїхали, відстрілялися і одразу втекли з тої вогневої позиції.
Пересиділи, з'явилася ціль, знову виїхали, відстрілялися, поїхали.
А зараз все. Закрита позиція.
Отак у нас зараз відбувається.
Чому так - можна зрозуміти зі звуків у повітрі.
Над лінією фронту постійно кружляють безпілотники.
Артилерійське знаряддя - ласі цілі для обох сторін.
Тож часто можна почути вибухи від "прильотів".
Раніше артилеристи відкрито пересувалися дорогами -
нині намагаються ховати техніку.
Частковий захист дає каркас із дротяної сітки -
дрони-камікадзе вибухають, врізаючись у неї, а не в бронетехніку.
Ця гаубиця на озброєнні вже кілька десятиліть.
У радянській армії артилерію називали на честь квітів,
приміром, ця називається "Гвоздика".
Сучасні західні установки, звісно, ефективніші,
але поступаються гаубицям радянської доби
у швидкості обслуговування та ремонту.
З гумором таким скажу, що ми можемо піти і майже
будь-яку деталь купити в якомусь автомагазині.
Але коли виходить зі строю натівська техніка, нам потрібно
буде викликати спеціальних людей зі спеціальними інструменти.
Екіпаж отримує координати цілі та швидко готується.
Відпрацювавши, вони одразу відходять подалі від гаубиці.
Кожен постріл з цієї позиції збільшує ймовірність бути виявленим.
Є така загальна думка, що вони там ідіоти. Це далеко не так.
Вони теж вміють воювати. Вони знають, що вони роблять.
Вони розвиваються, вчаться. Ну, і ми не відстаємо.
САУ знову ховають під захисним каркасом, тепер вона схована
від дронів. І "Гвоздика" чекає свого наступного завдання.
Те, що Росія значно покращила свої військові спроможності,
підтверджують і західній військові експерти.
І застерігають: це справді несе серйозні загрози.
Росія адаптувалася. Вона має доволі просунуті можливості
електронної боротьби та глушіння сигналу.
Вона також збільшила виробництво дронів.
Вона має велику кількість артилерійських знарядь,
які вона отримала і ще отримає додаткову артилерію,
наприклад, з Північної Кореї. Ми, звичайно, знаємо і про
безпілотники та ракети з Ірану. І Росія загалом має більший потенціал
для виробництва зброї. Вона перевела свою економіку
на воєнний лад. Вона нарощувала своє військове виробництво
таким чином, що змогла певною мірою обійти санкції.
Крім того, у неї набагато більше чоловіків.
Тож Україні потрібно зараз певною мірою врівноважити це
більш просунутими технологіями.
Це розуміють і союзники України.
На початку тижня з неоголошеним візитом прибув до Києва
глава Пентагону Ллойд Остін. За його словами, новий пакет
військової допомоги від США на 100 мільйонів доларів охоплює,
зокрема, зимове спорядження, і ЗСУ загалом мають "необхідні засоби,
щоб домогтися успіху в боях узимку", запевнив Остін.
Я думаю, українські військові готові до бойових дій узимку.
І, звісно, торік вони виконали чудову роботу.
Цього року ми очікуємо, що вони будуть базуватися на тому,
що сказав президент Зеленський, щоб вони були
ще навіть більш агресивними.
Одразу за Остіном до Києва прибув і міністр оборони Німеччини
Борис Пісторіус і теж оголосив про новий пакет військової допомоги.
У цей пакет входять ще чотири системи IRIS T SLM,
артилерійські боєприпаси калібру 155 мм і протитанкові міни.
Загалом це пакет на 1 мільярд 300 мільйонів євро.
І я впевнений, що цей уже п'ятий пакет від минулої зими
допоможе вам у боротьбі з російською агресією.
У перші місяці війни військові оглядачі дивувалися,
як повільно і незграбно російські війська змінювали свою тактику
після провалу плану "Київ за три дні".
Нині ж сталися серйозні зміни, зауважують західні військові
експерти, і Росія спромоглася адаптуватися до нових реалій.
Якщо ти не адаптуєшся, ти помреш. І росіяни адаптувалися.
Зокрема вони намагаються завести війну в глухий кут.
Тож вони звели великі мінні поля та дуже потужну оборону на передовій,
тому що вони розуміють, що якщо їм вдасться нав'язати таку війну,
як зараз, з незначними рухами з обох сторін, то зрештою щось станеться,
наприклад, унаслідок президентських виборів у США.
Це означатиме, що підтримка Заходу може, це не однозначно,
але може зменшитися. І це дає Росії можливість заморозити
лінію фронту на більш тривалий період,
на більш довгострокове розмежування території.
Ось що зробила Росія. Вони перейшли до повністю оборонної
війни в надії, що з часом щось станеться, що допоможе їм.
Тим часом українські війська, зокрема тут, під Бахмутом,
готуються не лише до адаптованої тактики росіян, а й до холодів.
Замість цієї багнюки незабаром буде сніг.
Це вже не перша зима на фронті для цього командира підрозділу РСЗВ.
Минулої зими ми працювали трохи по-іншому.
Ми майже постійно перебували на вогневих позиціях.
Більше працювали. У нас більше було боєприпасів.
То ми десь доба через добу чергували, тому що довше…
У нас не було таких умов, у нас невириті були бліндажі.
Зараз, звичайно, ми більше підготовлені.
Нині, розповідають у цьому підрозділі, докучають не лише
російська війська, а й… миші. Це не просто неприємно, а й небезпечно,
бо вони перегризають кабелі в техніці та роблять іншу шкоду.
Ось... Вони без бронежилетів...
Минулої зими я якось не помітив, щоб були миші.
Але цієї осені, вже, можна сказати, початок зими, то вже дуже багато.
Не знаєш, як з ними боротися.
Наприклад, сьогодні я ліг спати, поклав цю флісочку під голову,
зранку прокидаюся, а в мене тут цифри та літери
вона вже повиїдала трохи…
Військові кажуть, що до зими вже більш-менш підготувалися.
Є дизельні обігрівачі, теплий одяг та віра в перемогу.